und die notwendigen Entscheidungen
vorbereitet und getroffen
wie Sie wissen sind eine ganze Reihe von
Entscheidung seither getroffen worden
zum Beispiel dass wir flüssiggast
Terminals an den norddeutschen Küsten
bauen und pipelinster zu errichten zum
Beispiel dass wir jetzt dafür Sorge
tragen dass die Speicher gefüllt werden
mit gesetzlichen Vorgaben die wir gerade
jetzt noch mal weiter
präzisieren und wo wir dafür Sorge
tragen dass die Speicher schneller
gefüllt werden müssen wir haben
überhaupt dafür gesorgt dass es eine
solche Verpflichtung gibt zum Beispiel
dadurch dass wir entschieden haben dass
die Kohlekraftwerke wieder laufen und
uns dadurch in die Lage versetzen Gas
einzusparen zum Beispiel dadurch dass
wir entschieden haben dass für die
Transporte von Kohle auf Zügen auch eine
Priorität eingeräumt wird und durch
viele Sparmaßnahmen über diese der
Bundesminister für Wirtschaft gestern
informiert hat und die wir in der
Regierung vorbereitet haben
heute haben wir uns mit der Zukunft des
Unternehmens Juniper beschäftigt und
dazu auch wichtige Entscheidung
getroffen bevor ich auf diesen konkreten
Fall und die Konsequenzen eingehe will
ich aber doch die Prinzipien nach denen
wir handeln angesichts dieser
Herausforderung für unser Land und für
Europa und für die ganze Welt sprechen
you'll never walk alone
dass wir gemeinsam die schwierigen
Zeiten bewältigen dass wir
zusammenhalten dass es entscheidend
niemand wird mit seinen
Herausforderungen und Problemen alleine
gelassen keine einzelne Bürgerin kein
einzelner Bürger auch nicht die
Unternehmen in diesem Land wir sind
gemeinsam stark genug dass auch zu
schaffen und werden dieses und das
nächste Jahr unsere Probleme gemeinsam
meistern und wir werden alles
Erforderliche tun was getan werden muss
damit das auch gemeinsam gelingt und wir
werden es so lange tun wie das
erforderlich ist
das Unternehmen Juniper ist in große
Schwierigkeiten geraten ein Unternehmen
das von überragender Bedeutung ist für
die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung unseres
Landes für die Energieversorgung der
einzelnen Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber
auch viele Unternehmen es hat Gas
eingekauft bei vielen die das ihm zur
Verfügung gestellt haben unter anderem
auch bei Gazprom und Russland diese
Lieferung sind wie wir alle wissen nicht
mehr sicher dass das möglich ist hat
mich schon im Dezember letzten Jahres
bewegt und dazu geführt dass die von mir
eben beschriebene Runde zusammenkommt
und heute wieder zusammengetreten ist um
notwendige Entscheidungen zu treffen
das Gast
uniper eingekauft hat und an seine
Kunden weiter verkauft wird teilweise
nicht geliefert das Unternehmen muss
dieses Gas also zu viel höheren Preisen
zu aktuellen Weltmarktpreise neu
beschaffen und dadurch entsteht eine
schwierige Lage für das Unternehmen weil
es die Preise dieses bezahlt wird das
Gas nicht weitergeben kann an seine
Kunden und deshalb nicht in der Lage ist
die finanziellen Aufgaben zu bewältigen
ohne dass wir jetzt gemeinsam dem
Unternehmen unter die Arme greifen wir
haben mit den Anteilseignern und der
finnischen Regierung die an dem
Anteilseigner beteiligt ist gesprochen
und uns auf eine Lösung verständigt die
Lösung lautet wir werden einsteigen bei
uniper
mit 30% am Anteil des Unternehmens wir
werden die Aktien dieses Unternehmens
zum Nennwert kaufen das ist gegenwärtig
ein das ist ein 70 sie wissen dass der
gegenwärtige Börsenkurs über zehn Euro
liegt und können sich vorstellen dass
darin ein substanzieller Beitrag der
bisherigen Gesellschafter zur Rettung
dieses Unternehmens liegt weil sie
gewissermaßen entsprechend mit ihrem
Eigentum verbessert werden
gleichzeitig werden wir
pflichtwandel Anleihen zur Verfügung
stellen von bis zu 7,7 Milliarden Euro
als
hybrides Eigenkapital damit das
Unternehmen sicher die Herausforderung
bewältigen kann und die schon bestehende
kreditdienet der KfW von zwei Milliarden
auf 9 Milliarden Euro ausweiten alle
Maßnahmen zusammen werden dazu beitragen
dass das Unternehmen jetzt in der Lage
ist stabil alle notwendigen
Investitionsentscheidungen alle
notwendigen
Einkaufsentscheidung und auch alle
notwendigen Entscheidungen für die
Fortführung des Unternehmens zu treffen
und stabil in die Zukunft blicken kann
was wir auch wissen ist dass die höheren
Weltmarktpreise für Energie ob das nun
Kohlen oder Öl oder Gas ist früher oder
später bei uns allen bemerkbar werden
viele haben das hier zu Lande schon
gemerkt die Preise sind schon gestiegen
nicht nur an der Tankstelle und bei der
Heizölrechnung alles wird teurer wenn
man sich zu den heutigen Preisen auf den
Weltmärkten bedienen muss das wird
früher oder später für alle bemerkbar
sein
und deshalb haben wir jetzt schon eine
ganze Reihe von Maßnahmen ergriffen um
die Bürgern und Bürger durch diese Zeit
zu bringen und sie dabei zu unterstützen
ich sagte es ja schon niemand wird
alleine in die Zukunft gehen müssen wir
werden niemand mit seinen
Herausforderungen alleine lassen 30
Milliarden umfassen die
entlastungspakete die wir bereits auf
den Weg gebracht haben und da sind eine
ganze Reihe von Maßnahmen
festgelegt die teilweise jetzt erst
greifen am populärsten diskutiert sind
die Unterstützungsmaßnahmen mit dem
neuen euro-ticket und den verbilligten
Preisen an den Tankstellen durch Steuer
Verzicht für drei Monate aber wir haben
auch zum Beispiel die Belastung des
Strompreises mit der EEG-Umlage um über
20 Milliarden Euro reduziert indem wir
das in den Bundeshaushalt übernommen
haben ab dem Beginn des laufenden Monats
wir haben darüber hinaus entschieden
dass wir steuerlich Entlastung machen
die Arbeitnehmer
Pauschale ist angehoben worden der
Grundfreibetrag ist angehoben worden die
Pendlerpauschale ist angehoben worden
wir haben den Wohngeld beziehen ein
Heizkostenzuschuss gezahlt wir haben
dafür gesorgt dass arme Familien besser
unterstützt werden in dem 20 Euro mehr
pro Monat für ihre Kinder gezahlt werden
alle Familien haben pro Kind 100 Euro in
Aussicht gestellt bekommen und die
werden ausgezahlt wir haben dafür
gesorgt dass die Grundsicherung um 200
Euro angehoben wird wir haben eine
energiepreispauschale auf den Weg
gebracht und wir haben durch dieses
gesamte Maßnahmenbündel dazu beigetragen
dass es eine erhebliche Entlastung für
viele gibt das ist auch richtig so denn
die Belastung werden ja wie ich eben
geschildert haben auch dauerhaft für uns
alle als Bürgern und Bürger als
konsumente und Konsumenten aber auch als
Unternehmen spürbar sein und deshalb ist
sind wir uns darüber einig dass wir auch
dauerhaft weitere Entlastung auf den Weg
bringen müssen und das wollen wir auch
im Zusammenhang mit den Entscheidungen
die wir heute getroffen haben noch mal
unterstreichen denn zu den notwendigen
Maßnahmen damit die Unternehmen eine
Perspektive hat gehört auch dass es ab
an bestimmten Zeitpunkt seine höheren
Einkaufspreise auch weitergeben kann
geplant ist jetzt zum ersten zehnten
vielleicht auch etwas früher schon zum
ersten neunten je nachdem wie viel neu
beschafft werden muss kann das zu einer
Erhöhung der Gaspreise um die dann
weitergegeben werden und je nachdem wie
groß der Haushalt ist wird das durchaus
auch spürbar werden dann für die
einzelnen Haushalte wenn es um Bürgern
und Bürger gibt das kann schon sein dass
damit noch mal zusätzliche Belastung
verbunden sind die 200 oder 300 Euro für
eine vierköpfige Familie im Jahr
betragen können
deshalb wie gesagt bleibt es nicht bei
den entlastungspaketen von 30 Milliarden
sondern wir werden weitere Maßnahmen auf
den Weg bringen und die Konturen davon
haben wir in diesem Zusammenhang schon
einmal
miteinander besprochen und festgelegt
das erste ist es wird zum Anfang des
nächsten Jahres eine große
wohngeldreform geben darüber sind wir
uns in der Regierung einig wir wollen
den Kreis der Berechtigten Haushalte
ausweiten so dass mehr Bürgern und
Bürger Arbeitnehmern Arbeitnehmer
Rentner und Rentner ganz besonders die
auch davon an darauf Ansprüche haben
davon profitieren können und wir wollen
in diese wohngeldreform eine
Heizkostenpauschale gewissermaßen
dauerhaft integrieren wir haben uns auch
verpflichtet im Zusammenhang für die
Studenten etwas zu tun und in ihrem
Regime auch Heizkostenzuschüsse mit
unterzubringen das wird jetzt im
Einzelnen diskutiert und vorbereitet die
zweite große Maßnahme die auf alle Fälle
kommen wird ist dass wir uns dazu
verpflichten
dass wir die im Koalitionsvertrag von
der Regierung auf den Weg vereinbarte
bürgergeldreform definitiv zum ersten
Januar des nächsten Jahres in Kraft
setzen werden die Einzelheiten werden
wie sie schon gemerkt haben jetzt
miteinander diskutiert aber das ist die
Grundlage dafür dass wir eine
substanzielle Entlastung derjenigen die
am wenigsten haben zustande bringen
können und sie besser stellen können das
wollen wir im einzelnen auch zustande
bringen wir werden das definitiv
ergänzen indem wir Maßnahmen die wir
auch schon während der konfit 19
Pandemie ergriffen haben noch mal neu
prüfen zum Beispiel dass wenn Bürgern
und Bürger im Einzelnen Schwierigkeiten
haben durch die plötzlich veränderten
Umstände ihre gaststrom oder
Heizrechnung zu bezahlen oder mit ihrer
Miete zurechtzukommen dort in ein
rechtlicher Schutz gewährt wird das
hatten wir schon einmal eingeführt und
dazu sind jetzt die zuständigen
Ministerien beauftragt diese Frage im
Einzelnen durchdenken und dazu konkrete
Vorschläge vorzulegen
das ist das was auf alle Fälle geschieht
es wird ergänzt um viele Maßnahmen die
wir in der konzertierten
Aktionen diskutieren wollen sie wissen
genau dass wir zusammengekommen sind mit
den Unternehmensverbänden mit den
Arbeitgebern mit den Gewerkschaften mit
der Bundesbank dem Sachverständigenrat
um als Regierung zu diskutieren über das
was wir zu tun haben damit wir die
Bürgern und Bürger entlasten können
damit wir wirklich wahr machen können
dass wir hier uns unterhaken und alle
gemeinsam handeln das nächste Treffen
wird Mitte September sein ist auch schon
eingeladen und bei diesem Treffen werden
wir dann konkreter diskutieren mit all
den Beteiligten was über das hinaus was
ich eben hier skizziert habe noch zu tun
ist da gibt es viele konkrete gute
Vorschläge die dann auch mit dazugehören
dass wir eine gute Entlastung für die
Bürgern und Bürger organisieren können
für das was für die Zukunft notwendig
ist
und das wird ganz konkret dort beredet
neben den Maßnahmen die dort eine Rolle
spielen werden wir erneut das nutzen was
wir jetzt schon an Erfahrung gewonnen
haben in einer krisenhaften Situation
zur Stabilisierung von Unternehmen dazu
gehört zum Beispiel dass wir
die Kreditprogramme für Unternehmen bis
zu einer gewissen Größenordnung über die
KfW absichern so dass da jetzt plötzlich
hohe Energiepreise hat vielleicht auch
Investitionen tätig muss um Energie zu
sparen nicht wegen der schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen Lage
nicht so einfach in der Lage ist das
tatsächlich auch zu bewältigen deshalb
werden wir solche Bürgschaften ab
bürgschaftsabsicherung machen auch
oberhalb von 80 Prozent wie wir das auch
in der Vergangenheit getan haben wir
werden die bürgschaftsprogramme über das
Jahresende verlängern die notwendig sind
um in dieser Situation klarzukommen wir
werden dafür Sorge tragen dass wir die
Möglichkeiten die wir geschaffen haben
für sehr energieintensive Unternehmen
die jetzt ganz plötzlich mit sehr hohen
zusätzlichen Belastung
zu kämpfen haben die zuschussprogramme
die wir auf den Weg gebracht haben zu
verlängern über
Monat September hinaus und wir werden
auch
eigenkapitalhilfen wie wir das jetzt am
Fall Juniper ganz konkret durchführen
für die Zukunft für Unternehmen weiter
bereitstellen damit nichts
systemrelevante Unternehmen an den
Herausforderungen dieser Situation
scheitern alles zusammen eine umfassende
starke Botschaft die wir hier aussenden
und ich will zurückkommen zu dem was ich
am Anfang gesagt haben will you never
walk alone wir werden das tun was
erforderlich ist und so lange wie das
notwendig ist und wir werden als Land
stabil durch die Herausforderung kommen
die uns angesichts des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die Ukraine auf den
Energiemärkten begegnen schönen Dank
Herr Bundeskanzler ich hätte ganz gerne
gefragt ob mit dieser uniper Rettung
jetzt auch ein Modell geschaffen wurde
für die Rettung von anderen
Gasversorgern ist damit dieser
limaneffekt vor dem der
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck gewarnt hatte
abgewendet und können Sie noch mal genau
sagen bei der Weitergabe der Preise um
welchen Faktor es dabei geht also werden
die gesamten Gaspreise umgelegt auf die
Kunden oder nur ein Teil
schönen Dank für die Fragen zunächst mal
ist jedes Unternehmen ein Einzelfall es
gibt keine Blaupausen aber wir zeigen
dass wir in der Lage sind und am
Eigenkapital von Unternehmen zu
beteiligen dass wir eine solidarische
Vorgehensweise entwickeln können mit den
Anteilseignern der Unternehmen die auch
etwas dazu beitragen dass das
Unternehmen durch eine so schwierige
Zeit kommt und mit Milliarden
entsprechend ihren Beitrag dafür leisten
dass das funktioniert denn das ist ja
mit der anteilsübernahme verbunden das
gleiche gilt übrigens soweit die
Pflichtwandelanleihe in Anspruch
genommen werden bedeutet das ja auch am
Ende früher oder später eine höhere
Beteiligung des Bundes an den
Unternehmen was ist das Prinzip wir
können nicht verhindern dass wenn über
wenn neue Verträge abgeschlossen werden
müssen weil die alten ausgelaufen sind
sich die höheren Preise auf den
Energiemärkten Stück für Stück
durchschlagen das wird uns alle als
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und auch die
Unternehmen früher oder später treffen
dafür gibt es keinen wirksamen Schutz
die Notwendigkeit allerdings den zu
helfen die damit nicht klarkommen können
deshalb die bisherigen entlastungspakete
deshalb auch die Bereitschaft noch mehr
zu tun mindestens das was ich eben
skizziert habe und noch das dazu worüber
wir uns in der konzertierten Aktion mit
Gewerkschaften Arbeitgeberverbänden
Unternehmen verständigen
es geht also jetzt um Unternehmen
die
Verträge abgeschlossen haben die gelten
über den Kauf von Gast dass Sie
weiterverkaufen wollen
und das Prinzip ist dass 90 Prozent des
differenzpreises zwischen dem Preis den
sie eigentlich zahlen müssten für die
nicht bedienten und nicht
eingehaltenen Verträge und dem Vertrag
dann aus umgelegt werden auf die
Gesamtheit der Verbraucher Unternehmen
Wirtschaftsbetriebe und eben auch
einzelne Bürgern und Bürger das am Ende
mittragen damit nicht einzelne die ja
nichts dafür können dass Ihr Lieferant
gewissermaßen zufällig
Opfer ist der Nichteinhaltung Verträge
von Verträgen durch Gazprom und und
Russland das nicht so zufällig trifft
aber natürlich wird irgendwann mal wenn
überhaupt neue Verträge abzuschließen
sind mit denjenigen die kohleöl Gas auf
dem Weltmarkt anbieten das dann auch
wirksam werden für die wirtschaftlichen
Verhältnisse hier zu Lande und übrigens
in jedem anderen Land der Welt
ich glaube ich habe Ihre Fragen
beantwortet
mit den 90 Prozent das ist der Anteil
der dann an die Bürger weitergegeben wer
da habe ich das richtig verstanden 1990%
Differenzbetrages wird umgewicht an auf
die Unternehmen das sind ja die
hauptkonten dieser Lieferanten und dann
auch die privaten Endverbraucher wie wir
alle
Herr Bundeskanzler wenn ein
Bundeskanzler sein spärlichen Urlaub
unterbricht dann ist das ja erstmal
Alarmstimmung und deswegen noch einmal
die Frage nach dem Vergleich zur Lehman
Brothers pleite ist das jetzt der Punkt
an dem sie sagen wenn wir das jetzt
nicht verhindern dann gibt es eine
Kettenreaktion und einen und weltweite
Auswirkungen und eine Frage zur
übergewinnsteuer ist das dann nicht auch
der Zeitpunkt wo Firmen doch zur Kasse
gebeten werden müssen die bisher als
Kriegsgewinnler erschienen
das ist notwendig gewesen dass wir das
Unternehmen Juniper jetzt stabilisieren
deshalb habe ich das sehr früh gesagt
auch andere haben sich entsprechend
eingelassen weil das auch zur Beruhigung
aller Beteiligten notwendig war
derjenigen die finanzbeziehung mit dem
Unternehmen haben die sich darauf
verlassen dass das Unternehmen
seinerseits seine Verpflichtung
einhält und dafür sorgt dass wir alle
durch diese Zeit kommen wenn ich das
richtig im Kopf habe sind etwa 60
Prozent der des gastimports werden
letztendlich über diesen Händler dann
auch in bestimmter Weise in Deutschland
organisiert das ist ein sehr sehr großer
Batzen und deshalb ist es klar dass man
sich vorstellen kann das ist praktisch
kein Unternehmen gegeben hätte dass an
dem Ende dieser Lieferketten hängt das
nicht davon betroffen wäre und Einzel
hätten vielleicht das gar nicht für sich
lösen können das gleiche gilt für uns
alle als Verbraucher und Verbraucher und
deshalb ist das schon wichtig gewesen
dass immer klar war dass wir das
Unternehmen stabilisieren werden und
dass das auch ein großer Kraftakt ist
der erforderlich ist aber diesen großen
Kraftakt stemmen wir das haben wir heute
entschieden
wir haben jetzt über die Maßnahmen
gesprochen die wir bereits auf den Weg
gebracht haben über die Maßnahmen die
wir zusätzlich auf den Weg bringen
wollen auf alle Fälle ich habe in die
skizziert und wir haben darüber hinaus
gesagt dass natürlich noch vieles
Weitere zu verhandeln sein wird im
Zusammenhang mit der konzertierten
Aktion
ja könnten sie noch mal einmal kurz
sagen ob die
aufspaltungspläne die ja die finnische
Regierung verfolgt hat ob das jetzt vom
Tisch ist wenn ich das richtig lese
bekommt der wohl auch Ford um ein
bisschen
Geld und
zweite Frage ist das mit dem Linden alle
schon soweit abgesprochen die
Finanzierung dieser neuen Entlastungen
ich bin habe ich spreche hier als
Bundeskanzlerin der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und das was ich hier
vorgestellt habe ist eine gemeinsame
Entscheidung der Regierung über die ich
an vollständiges Einvernehmen habe mit
dem
Wirtschaftsminister und dem
Finanzminister
das haben wir sehr sorgfältig in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen diskutiert
übrigens immer sehr konstruktiv weil es
ja notwendig war dass wir hier gemeinsam
handeln müssen und es ist so dass wir
uns nach Erörterung aller verschiedene
Alternativen wie man eine Stabilisierung
des Unternehmens zustande bekommen kann
für diese entschieden haben weil sie die
plausibelste ist weil sie zu die
geringsten rechtlichen Schwierigkeiten
mit sich bringt und auch eine gute
fortführungsperspektive für das
Unternehmen als Ganzes mit sich bringt
das ist ja auch etwas worum es geht dann
da geht es ja auch um Beschäftigte um
vieles andere was eine Rolle spielt für
die Zukunftsfähigkeit des Unternehmens
Juniper leistet Beiträge einmal in dem
die Gesellschaft davon uniper leisten an
Beitrag weil mit dem Einstieg des Bundes
ja letztendlich ihre Beteiligung weniger
Wert wird weil ihr Anteil an geringerer
wird am gesamten Unternehmen das ist ein
milliardenschwerer Betrag und außerdem
ist vereinbart dass die
Kreditlinien und die Garantien die
abgegeben worden sind weiter bestehen
bleiben da geht es ungefähr zweimal um
vier Milliarden Euro also auch durchaus
eine Menge Geld
Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben mehrfach
gesagt you never walk alone ich würde
das gerne auf die europäische Ebene
einmal transportieren was ist der
aktuelle Stand in Sachen
solidaritätsabkommen mit Polen wann
kommt das im Winter wäre es ja zu spät
das zu diskutieren und dann natürlich
die Sorge auch dass diese aktuelle
gasversorgungskrise sich ausweiten
könnte auf andere Energiebereiche im
Anschluss die Frage was ist ihre
Reaktion auf den Vorstoß in Polen bei
einigen Politikern dass man AKW in
Deutschland pachten könnte ist das für
sie eine Option danke
zunächst mal
ist aus meiner Sicht völlig klar dass
die Europäische Union solidarisch
handeln muss und ich bin auch sicher
wird wenn es um die Herausforderung geht
und die Europäische Kommission hat ja
mit ihrem Vorschlag schon die Richtung
vorgegeben für uns alle ist es wichtig
dass wir jetzt mit größter
Geschwindigkeit darüber nachdenken wie
man insbesondere Gas einsparen kann
viele sind ja sowieso dabei und haben
längst Investitionen geplant gut wenn
man sie jetzt vorziehen kann wenn das
möglich ist das wäre ein ganz wichtiger
Beitrag es gibt viele Maßnahmen über die
der Wirtschaftsminister gesprochen hat
und ich habe eingangs gesagt dass wir ja
schon seit Anfang des Jahres sehr
weitreichende sehr sehr strategische
sehr substanzielle Entscheidung
getroffen haben die einerseits die
verbrauche betreffen indem wir auf zum
Beispiel Kohlekraftwerke zurückgreifen
indem wir einspeichern und indem wir
andere importmöglichkeiten für Gas
schaffen mit erheblichen Investitionen
in die Infrastruktur und mit Gesetzen
die das schnell möglich machen wer hätte
vor einem Jahr
zugestimmt dass es klappen kann dass wir
gasimport aus neuen Terminals an der
norddeutschen Küste Anfang des nächsten
Jahres beginnen werden innerhalb einer
Zeitraums von wenigen Monaten das ist
schon substanziell wenn man bedenkt wie
viele Widerstände es in der
Vergangenheit gegen solche
Entscheidungen getroffen gegeben hat ich
erinnere mich noch an manche Kritik die
mich erreicht hat als ich vor Jahren das
schon einmal vorgeschlagen habe und
außerdem geht es ja auch um viele
rechtliche Veränderungen die wir auf den
Weg gebracht haben das ist das was man
gegenwärtig machen kann ich glaube dass
wir alle wissen dass die Herausforderung
vor der wir stehen eine ist die sich in
diesem und dem nächsten Jahr vor allem
stellen wird wir sind sehr sehr früh
bewusst gewesen dass wir was tun müssen
deshalb sind wir auch sehr gut in der
Vorbereitung der Dinge die man
unternehmen muss und glauben dass man
durchkommt trotzdem prüfen wir natürlich
alle Möglichkeiten immer noch mal neu
durch also sie wissen dass sehr sehr
harte Worst Case-Szenario Berechnung in
Auftrag gegeben worden sind die schauen
wir uns an und wenn daraus etwas zu
schließen ist werden wir daraus auch
Schlüsse ziehen ansonsten Solidarität in
Europa gilt für alle Mitgliedsstaaten
und gilt auch unbedingt
Herr Bundeskanzler durch nordstream 1
fließt du der russisches Gas ich würde
interessieren ob sie das beruhigt oder
ob sie weiterhin die Unsicherheit sehen
dass die Gaslieferung aus Russland
komplett eingestellt werden und und im
Zusammenhang damit es hat ja vereinzelt
auch Forderungen gegeben Nord Stream 2
notfalls im Betrieb zu nehmen ist das
für sie eine Option oder schließen Sie
das aus zumindest solange es den Krieg
in der Ukraine gibt
das ist doch sehr klar es gibt mehrere
Pipelines die Deutschland erreichen
immer ein Teil der Kapazitäten würde
ausreichen um die
Lieferverpflichtung Russlands zu
erfüllen ob das nun die Pipeline über
die Ukraine ist die jamai-pipeline oder
Nord Stream 1 also 3 funktionierende
Pipelines sind da und es wäre technisch
niemals ein Problem sämtliche Lieferer
Verpflichtung die russland hat
einzuhalten und für uns war wichtig dass
weil so plötzlich im Raum stand dass der
turnusmäßige Wechsel der Turbine der gar
nicht jetzt Anstand sondern jetzt stand
die Lieferung an ein Grund sein könnte
für die technischen Gründe die
vorgebrachten Gründe für technische
Rahmenbedingungen die zu einer
Reduzierung der lieferströme führen
nicht stimmt deshalb haben wir uns darum
bemüht dass die Turbine auch tatsächlich
zu Ende gewartet wird und aus Kanada
nach Deutschland von uns aus nach
Russland kommen kann die wissen es gibt
gar keinen erdgasembargo weder seitens
der europä Union noch seitens der G7 aus
guten wohl überlegten gründen und das
ist schon eine bemerkenswerte Botschaft
dass die jahrzehntelange Behauptung egal
was ist ob es gute oder schlechte Zeiten
sind die vereinbarten gasflüsse werden
immer stattfinden jetzt nun gar nicht so
stimmt technische Gründe sind an vielen
Stellen vorgebracht worden nicht nur bei
der nordstream 1 Pipeline und sie sind
wenn man da tiefer reingeht genauso
wenig überzeugend wie diejenigen die uns
begegnet sind deshalb fahren wir lieber
Nummer sicher und deshalb haben wir uns
sehr klar entschieden dass wir
rechtzeitig anfangen Strukturen zu bauen
mit dem wir auch anderswoher Gast
importieren können und rechtzeitig
Maßnahmen zu treffen den Gasverbrauch zu
reduzieren zum Beispiel durch das
Wiederanfahren von Kohlekraftwerken und
zum Beispiel durch das Aufbauen einer
speicherreserve so ein Gesetz hat ja in
der Vergangenheit nicht existiert das
haben wir jetzt neu gemacht aus gutem
Grund weil wir wissen es wird nicht
sicherer dass es jetzt ist man kann
nicht sich fest auf etwas verlassen als
ein Vertrag wird nicht sicher
eingehalten nur weil er fünfmal
unterschrieben ist und darauf bereiten
wir uns besser vor natürlich
wäre es gut ist Kim anders und es würde
einfach geliefert
Herr Bundeskanzler uns würde
interessieren inwiefern stellen Sie
sicher dass bei uniper nicht nur die
Steuerzahler am Ende bezahlen sondern
auch die Anteilseigner
die Frage
ist eigentlich durch das Konzept
beantwortet dass wir jetzt auf den Weg
gebracht haben wir haben ja gesagt dass
sich das wir uns am Eigenkapital des
Unternehmens beteiligen
die Aktie wir werden 30 Prozent der
Anteile übernehmen die kaufen wir zum
Wert von ein Euro 70 das ist der
Nennbetrag wenn sie mal gucken in die
Börsenkurse das schmeckt natürlich jetzt
auch wegen unserer Entscheidung gerade
alle ein bisschen aber die sind glaube
ich alle über 10 Euro gegenwärtig das
ist wenn sie das mal zusammenrechnen
schon ein milliardenschwerer Beitrag der
Eigentümer von Juniper zur Sanierung
ihrer eigenen Gesellschaft und natürlich
hoffen glauben wir dass mit den
Maßnahmen die wir auf den Weg gebracht
haben das Unternehmen so stabilisiert
ist dass es auch seine Verpflichtung aus
diesem Verträgen früher oder später zu
erfüllen kann dass das für die
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler auch
gut ausgeht ich habe ja auch in anderer
Funktion solche Dinge schon einmal auf
den Weg gebracht während der großen
Auswirkungen der wirtschaftlichen Krise
wegen der kombit 19 Pandemie und das ist
ja auch für die Steuerzahler
Steuerzahler meistens eine
Erfolgsgeschichte und wir hoffen
natürlich für das Unternehmen und für
uns alle dass es hier wieder so wird
Herr Bundeskanzler sie sagten vorhin die
konzertierte Aktion soll Mitte September
über weitere Entlastungsmaßnahmen
beraten jetzt geht es ja die von Ihnen
angesprochenen Entlastungsmaßnahmen
Tankrabatt 9 Euro Ticket die aber schon
Ende August Auslaufen denkt die
Ampelkoalition darüber nach diese
Maßnahmen zu verlängern möglicherweise
auch direkt im Anschluss oder schließen
Sie das aus und die zweite Frage ist es
wird in Bayern ja intensiv darüber
diskutiert ob das Atomkraftwerk Isa 2
möglicherweise im streckbetrieb sechs
Monate länger laufen können soll wie ist
da ihre Haltung wäre das eine Option
wenn es zu Engpässen in Bayern kommt
zunächst mal was die konkreten Maßnahmen
betrifft
war von vorne rein gesagt dass die
Maßnahme die sich mit dem neuen
euro-ticket verbindet und die Maßnahme
die sich mit der dem weitgehenden Steuer
für so einen großen Steuer Verzicht im
Zusammenhang mit den Preisen an den
Tankstellen verbindet jeweils auf drei
Monate befristet sein sollen so ein
bisschen haben die natürlich die
Diskussion bestimmt
und dann ist ganz unbemerkt geblieben
was wir alles an vielen vielen anderen
Entlastung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger für die Unternehmen gleichzeitig
auf den Weg gebracht haben ein paar der
Maßnahmen und gar nicht alle habe ich
von noch einmal wiedergegeben und ich
hoffe so ein bisschen dass das nicht nur
durch Wiedergabe und erzählen sich auch
rumspricht sondern dass allmählich die
Leute das auch merken die 20 Euro für
die Kinder aus einem Familien kommen an
die 100 Euro für alle Familien kommen an
der Heizkostenzuschuss wird ausgezahlt
man merkt tatsächlich dass die
EEG-Umlage nicht mehr auf dem Strompreis
ist die 20 Milliarden sind jetzt eine
Entlastung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die steuerlichen Entlastung beim
Grundfreibetrag bei der
arbeitnehmerpauschale sind ja für immer
also da sind ja viele Maßnahmen
ergriffen worden die sich Stück für
Stück auswirken und diese beiden
Maßnahmen waren aber von vornherein
zeitlich befristet sie sollten das
Gesamtbudget diesen Jahres entlasten
aber weil wir ja nun sehr genau wissen
dass die Weltmärkte uns höhere
Energiepreise für längere Zeit bescheren
werden wird es so sein dass wir auch
dauerhaft was machen müssen und das geht
dann darüber hinaus und dazu dient die
konzertierte Aktion um das im Einzelnen
besprechen aber wir werden auch Dinge
daneben veranlassen und ich habe eben
deshalb gesagt ganz wichtig wird sein
dass tatsächlich das Bürgergeld zum 1
Januar 23 kommt dass wir ein umfassend
ausgeweitetes modernisiertes Wohngeld
sehr zielgenau für diejenigen die wenig
Geld verdienen als Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer als Rentner und Rentner zur
Verfügung stellen und dass das auch
hilft
was die Frage betrifft der
Energiesicherheit haben wir ja
Entscheidung getroffen die dazu
beitragen dass wir weniger Gas
verbrauchen indem wir zum Beispiel
Kohlekraftwerke wieder anfahren
entsprechend der gesetzlichen Regelung
die wir haben und damit Energie
unmittelbar sparen die Maßnahmen die wir
ansonsten ergreifen sollen ja auch dazu
beitragen dass die Nachfrage etwas
nachlässt und dadurch etwas entsteht
die
Stromproduktion nur darum geht es ja bei
der von Ihnen gestellten Frage und nur
ein ganz kleiner Teil der
Stromproduktion ist etwas das wir
ständig neu rechnen und ich habe eben
schon berichtet dass der Bundesminister
für Wirtschaft und Klima ja
eine verschärfte Worst Case Szenario
Berechnungen Auftrag gegeben hat die
gucken wir uns mal an
ja Bundeskanzler noch mal eine
Verständnisfrage sie sagten vorhin 200
bis 300 Euro pro Jahr mehr vor Haushalte
müsste man mit Rechnen einigen Fällen
ist das jetzt praktisch sie können
ausschließen dass diese Horrorszenarien
eintreten dass es dreifach oder vierfach
Preiserhöhungen für für Konsumenten
geben wird durch die dank der Maßnahmen
der Bundesregierung die jetzt kommen und
dann ganz kurz noch mal zu dem Lehman
Brother Moment Frage ist das jetzt sie
sagten ja mehrfach you never walk alone
ist das sozusagen jetzt dieser whatever
it takes Moment für den Energiesektor
den Sie hier gerade verkündet haben also
dass die dass sie praktisch alles
sicherstellen werden damit keine dieser
großen Energieunternehmen
zusammenbrechen
ich finde
dass es sehr klug war was Mario Draghi
seinerseits seinerzeit formuliert hatte
und ja auch dazu beigetragen hat das
ganz viele
schon verstanden haben dass das eine
schwierige Zeit ist aber dass Sie sich
darauf verlassen können dass diejenigen
die Verantwortung haben das Notwendige
tun werden und genauso ist es jetzt auch
wir werden alles Erforderliche tun damit
wir gemeinsam als Land als Unternehmen
als Bürgern und Bürger durch diese
Situation kommen damit niemand vor eine
für ihn selbst oder sie selbst unlösbare
Situation gestellt wird das ist schon
etwas wo man sich unterhaken muss und
solidarisch sein muss das hat Wirkung
für die eigene Sicherheit aber das hat
natürlich auch Wirkung für unser ganzes
Land denn wir werden das ja auch
bewältigen egal wie es kommt was ihnen
keiner hier seriös sagen können ist wie
sich die Preise für Energie auf den
Weltmärkten entwickeln werden das hängt
von den Angeboten ab das hängt von dem
von der Dauer des von Russland
angezettelten Krieges gegen die Ukraine
ab das hängt von vielen anderen Faktoren
ab die wir nicht alleine beeinflussen
können was wir aber versucht haben hin
zu kriegen ist dass wir so viel sparen
auch zum Beispiel durch das
wiederanlaufen von Kraftwerken die wir
eigentlich abgeschaltet haben im Bereich
der Kohle dass wir Vorsorge treffen
durch durch Speicherung in den
gasspeichern unserer Republik mit
gesetzlichen Vorgaben die wir jetzt noch
mal anschärfen auf 75 Prozent zum ersten
September und dann weiteren
steigungsraten in den Folgemonaten so
dass wir die so voll wie möglich kriegen
und dann natürlich durch den schon
beschriebenen Bau von neuen Import
Infrastrukturen die uns in Lage
versetzen Gast zu kaufen das wird
natürlich nicht billig werden aber es
ist ja die erste Frage haben wir genug
ausreichend zumindest dass wir gut durch
die Zeiten kommen für uns alle und
zweitens können wir das wirtschaftlich
bewältigen und gerade wenn es um das
wirtschaftliche bewältigen geht müssen
wir denjenigen helfen die in die Klemme
kommen durch diese Situation darüber
sind wir uns als Regierung auch einig
aber wie hoch das im Einzelnen sein wird
das kann niemand sagen ich habe gesagt
je nachdem und da muss man ganz
vorsichtig sein wie viel Gas gekauft
werden muss das teurer ist als das was
man die Grundlage der vertragsberechnung
war wird sich das auswirken das kann
zwei Cent
für die Kilowattstunde Gas
das kann aber auch ein höherer Betrag
sein wenn das ganz gut kommt könnte es
sogar weniger sein da wage ich aber
nicht dran zu glauben und das was wir
verhindern ist das einzelne den ganze
Wucht spüren sondern dass wir das auf
unsere gemeinsame Schultern verteilen
und dadurch dass etwas weniger wird und
das kann eben 200 das kann 300 Euro sein
pro Jahr das hängt ein bisschen davon ab
wie es kommt und das werden wir nicht
alleine bestimmen aber dass man vor
einer unlösbare Situation geschält wird
das wollen wir auf alle Fälle verhindern
durch diese Maßnahmen die das
Unternehmen stabilisieren durch diese
Umlage und dadurch dass wir gleichzeitig
aber auch zusätzlich zu den bereits
getroffenen Maßnahmen weitere
Entlastungsmaßnahmen in den Blick nehmen
in der konzertierten Aktion und in der
Konzeption die ich eben dargestellt habe
Bundeskanzler ich würde gerne zurück zu
diesem Vorschlag der Europäischen
Kommission zu kommen also die spanische
zur gasreduzierung
gasverbrauchsreduzierung die spanische
Ministerin Therese Ribera hat empört
darauf reagiert und gesagt dass wir
Spanier im Gegensatz zu anderen Ländern
in Sachen Energie verbraucht nicht über
unsere Verhältnisse gelebt haben
es statt sich die Frage warum müssten
Spanier und Portugiesen
Opfer bringen für die
energiepolitischen Fehler Deutschlands
danke meine Sicht ist dass wir alle vor
große Herausforderungen gestellt werden
kein Land kann sagen dass es nicht
berührt wird von den steigenden
Energiepreisen die weltweit eine Rolle
spielen und natürlich von den
Herausforderungen die sich im Hinblick
auf Gas geben
die Kommission hat wenn ich das richtig
sehr ihren Vorschlag ja auch so
entwickelt dass er differenziert im
Hinblick darauf ob man
also wie die verbrauche sind im Hinblick
darauf welche importstrukturen man hat
und ob das überhaupt weitergegeben
werden kann ganz besonders für Inseln
und Halbinseln wenn ich das so sagen
darf und insofern ist das ja auch sehr
also der Versuch da ausgewogen
vorzugehen ich sehe den Diskussionen
ganz
zuversichtlich entgegen da wird es
glaube ich genügend gemeinschaftliche
Solidarität geben und ich glaube wer
hierzulande
aber auch anderen Orts glaubt dass es
keinen Sinn macht sich darüber Gedanken
zu machen wie man die gasverbräuche
reduzieren kann
er ist irgendwie
erlebt auf dem anderen woanders also das
ist die gleiche Welt in der wir sind und
das ist ein weltumspannendes Problem
insofern keines einzelne Länder
noch mal kurz zu Juniper inwieweit ist
geplant mit dem Einstieg des Bundes auch
operativ in das Geschäft einzugreifen
insbesondere mit Blick auf den
Aufsichtsrat und der zweite Frage zu den
Entlastungen die sie in Aussicht
gestellt haben und die noch verhandelt
werden inwieweit glauben Sie dass das
mit der Schuldenbremse weiter vereinbar
sein wird danke
was die erste Frage betrifft wir wollen
nicht als Staat Unternehmer werden
natürlich werden wir wenn wir irgendwo
beteiligt sind ein bisschen Obacht geben
das mit unserem Geld ordentlich
umgegangen wird wie wir das auch
anderswo machen aber das ist jetzt nicht
die Perspektive die wir dafür folgen wir
werden auch also die die Idee hinter
allem ist auch dass es auch nicht dabei
bleiben muss dass wir da drin sind aber
jetzt ist das erstmal eine starke
Stabilisierung des Unternehmens und für
alle die da viele Fragen hatten empfehle
ich ein Blick ins Archiv die Debatten
die wir um einen anderen größeren
Einstieg in einem Unternehmen geführt
haben wo ich die gleichen Antworten
gegeben habe und hinterher hat sich
alles als wahr herausgestellt in Bezug
auf die weitere Entwicklung also kann
man vielleicht das die Perspektive
verfolgen dass wir da am trendfolgen den
wir schon mal richtig auf den Weg
gebracht haben
im übrigen ist es so dass wir bei den
Dingen die wir hier miteinander
diskutieren davon ausgehen dass wir die
finanzierungsspielräume haben die wir
dazu brauchen
schönen Dank